I've been struggling with an idea
recently that I was thinking maybe it'd be
able to help me out with basically in
a recent interview you talked about how
myth is meant to reconcile
inherent contradictions in reality,
right?
But I'm sort of stuck
between two mythological or
psychoanalytic ideas that I
think are both really important,
but they seem to have a
inherent contradiction within
them that I've been trying
to figure out.
So on one hand you have this idea that
there's times in your life where you have
to identify things in yourself that
are insufficient or there's a problem
somehow that you have to kind of have a
controlled burn or like a Phoenix like
transformation where you discard part
of yourself that doesn't fit or is not
working.
But then on the other hand,
you have talked about this,
this union idea where
as you become really,
when you get older,
you mature by reincorporating things
about yourself that you lost when you were
younger or that you know,
you're trying to integrate your shadow
or you're trying to find parts of your
personality that,
that maybe you've been rejecting and
trying to figure out how to bring them
into,
into the folder.
And then the whole,
so he's got this quote that I really like,
which is I'd rather be holding good.
Right?
Right.
So,
so on one hand you may identify something
as a problem and you want to get rid
of it or burn it off.
But then on the other hand,
it seems like the,
the path to being stronger is to figure
out how to put everything together.
So there's a,
there's a,
one of the things young wrote
about in his works on alchemy was,
um,
an explanation of the
prime l chemical dictum,
which was Solvay Coagula,
which meant dissolve and integrate.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
so imagine this,
imagine that.
Imagine you had a fairly hostile father
who is not very well controlled in his
aggression,
decent person other than that,
but let's say that,
and so your reaction is,
I'm never going to be aggressive.
And so you've built a like
a moral structure that's
part of your personality and
there's possibility floating around.
Outside of that,
did you,
you've denied an ethical,
you've denied any ethical.
Okay,
what would you say?
You've stripped the idea of aggression
of any ethical utility whatsoever.
Okay,
so what happens?
This burns off and then
that comes back up.
Now you still have to integrate it.
So it's associated in
some sense with niches,
ideas,
morality as cowardice.
Because one of nature's most trenchant
critiques of traditional morality,
let's say,
is that most of what passes
for morality isn't morality.
It's just cowardice.
It's not that I'm a good
person and I don't hurt you.
It's that I'm afraid to hurt you and
because I don't want to admit that I'm
afraid to hurt you.
Then I say I'm moral because then I can
mask my essential fear and cowardice in
a guise of morality.
And that happens far more often than you
would think because harmless and moral
are by no means the same thing.
So some of what you're burning off,
you can sit,
and this is where Freud was such a genius
I think is because he concentrated on
aggression in sexuality,
which are perhaps the two most difficult
parts of a personality to integrate.
So that,
um,
the,
the
hyper simplified morality stops you from
tapping into deeper recesses of your
psyche.
And it's partly because
there are primal forces.
It's not surprising that you don't
want to have anything to do with them,
that you stay away from situations where
they might make themselves manifest.
But the problem is by denying the
worst in yourself in that matter,
suppressing it,
you preclude the possibility of the
best because no one can be a good person
without integrating their
capacity for aggression.
Because without that
capacity for aggression,
you cannot say no.
Because no means,
if you really say it,
no means there isn't anything that you
can do to me that will make me change my
mind or,
or conversely it means I will play
for higher stakes than you will.
And unless you've got your
aggression integrated,
there isn't a chance you can say that.
And if you did,
no one would take you seriously
because they'd know it was just a show.
So one of the most useful
things that young did,
I think was to work on this idea of the
integration of the shadow because he was
really interested in the idea of evil,
right?
Especially working with trying to parcel
out what happened in Nazi Germany and
during the Second World War.
What do you do with the part of you
that's aggressive and potentially
malevolent?
You just crush it.
That's the super ego
response in some sense.
You just put it behind you,
so to speak.
Is that a possibility or do you admit
to its existence and bring it into the
game?
And that's
for,
for Freud.
In some sense,
morality was super ego clamping down
on the bed and there were fundamentally
opposed,
both young and Piaget
had a different idea.
And I think they were right.
It's like,
no,
you invite the bad guys I out to play.
And so you're an aggressive hockey player,
but it's disciplined
aggression that makes you,
gives you access to a whole source of
energy you wouldn't otherwise have.
And then with regards to sexuality,
it's like,
well,
untrammeled promiscuity
doesn't constitute a virtue,
but neither does unavoidable virginity.
Right?
In fact,
I think that's worse because it
also masks itself with virtue.
It's like,
well,
you should be able to,
you should be to do things
that you wouldn't do.
That's uh,
that's like the definition
of a genuinely moral person.
They could do it,
but they don't.
That's not cowardice.
And so that's,
you burn off the things that get
in the way of that integration.
So when you say dissolve in integrate
yet to be a good way to sort of bring the
two ideas together that the burning off
and the difficult processes necessary
because the elements of yourself are
structured together in a rigid way that is
not working properly.
Yeah,
that's what happens to Japan.
Low in the belly of the whale.
He's so caught in his presuppositions
that he can't escape right in.
So Pinocchio represents the new forest.
So it's very interesting.
So when You Watch Pinocchio,
tried to rescue him.
The first thing Japan,
Oh does is Confuse Pinocchio with a
fish because he wants something to eat.
But Pinocchio is better than something
to eat because he could rescue him.
So he doesn't need to eat.
And then Pinocchio wants to make a fire
in Japan objects because he's going to
burn up all the furniture.
So like we don't need the damn furniture
if we're getting out of the whale,
you know?
And so,
so Japan,
no,
and he's old.
So that,
that's,
that's the,
that's the rigid structure.
That's the old year that has to die
off before the new year can be born.
It's a forest fire that allows for new
growth and that's how those things are
put together and to see,
and it's useful to know too,
because if you burn something off,
you might think,
well,
there's nothing left.
It's like,
that's not true.
If it's dead wood,
then you have room for new growth and
you want to be doing that on a fairly
regular basis.
That's the,
that's that's the snake that sheds
its skin and transforms itself,
right?
That's,
that's the death and resurrection.
From a psychological perspective,
it's exactly the same idea.
Now we don't know the upper limit to that,
right,
because we don't know what a person
would be like if they let everything that
they could let go,
let go and only let in what was seemly,
let's say,
but you can see that.
It's funny,
we don't know that to some degree
you can see people very far.
You can see people start
to do that without,
that's not an rare experience.
And people improve very rapidly.
They can improve their lives very rapidly.
A lot of it's low hanging fruit.
Like if you just stopped doing really
stupid things that you know are stupid,
your life improves a lot.
So,
and it,
it frees you up.
It also means there's a,
there's an element there that's also
associated with pride because people tend
to take pride in who they are.
And that's a bad idea because that
stops you from becoming who you could be
because if you're proud of who you are,
you won't let that go when it's necessary.
You won't step away from it,
you know?
And then you end up being your own parody,
something like that.
That's also a very bad idea.
You want to be continually stepping
away from your previous self and so big.
And I guess part of that too is that you,
you have to decide,
you know,
are,
are you order,
are you chaos or are you the
process that mediates between them?
And if you're the process
that mediates between them,
you,
you are the thing that transforms and
that's the right attitude for human being
because that's what we are.
We're the thing that voluntarily
confronts chaos and transforms.
That's what we are.
And so for better or worse,
you know,
that's our deepest biological essence,
you might say.
And so you can let things go if you
know that there's more growth to come.